you know we're all doing it together and
it's fine but like there are those
people out there and the only reason
those people bother me is because I
think that it is I I'm a I'm a mother of
a
girl and it's dangerous what we put on
people it's dangerous I think to say to
women you can't you can't look like
you're not 22 to me anymore because I
don't know how to I don't know how to
take that okay well that's your problem
because I'm 44 and I this is what I look
like you know what I mean um so it just
it just bothered me in that way that I
feel like I just feel like we're and and
by the
way that whatever age it is I feel like
people maybe these people like have
picked they seem to have picked like
somewhere between 23 and 25 for me which
by the way she was a looker like
congratulations to that 23 or 25 but I'm
a different person now yeah you know um
and it's great but there's also
like that 23 and 25y old wasn't in her
body like at 23 24 25 I didn't feel
self-confident I felt watched I felt
like I had to be everything for
everybody all the time I was called sexy
before I ever knew what SE being sexy
was like I was 17 years old on the on
the cover of Maxim and I had no idea why
I was on the cover of Maxim I was I was
honored and I loved it but I was like
what you know I remember doing um
Heartbreakers at 23 and the director was
like we just need to be sexier and I had
to pull him aside and I was like I don't
know I don't know what that means I'm
only 23 I know that I'm supposed to be
this thing for people but I don't know
what that means and he had to like help
me figure that out you know and so it's
weird for me when people are like that's
the girl that we wanted you to be and
I'm like that girl was so insecure and
had so confused and like trying her best
but this girl who may not look the way I
I like who I am I feel good I'm fine hey
guys I'm doing another live podcast
downtown LA at the Regent Theater and my
special guest for January 24th is
Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad Jessica
Jones this is going to be a soul that
event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so excited